-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy- and Academy Award-winnin
actress you know from her work
on films such as "I, Tonya
and shows such as
"The West Wing" and "Mom."
She stars next in
"Breaking News in Yuba County,
which is on digital
and in select theaters
on February 12th.
Let's take a look.
-Next number.
-$23.50.
-Oh, I'm sorry. Uh, excuse me.
I think someone forgot
to finish the "E."
[ Chuckles ]
It should say "Happy Birthday,
Sue," not..."Suc."
[ Chuckles ]
-Cash or credit?
-Please welcome back to
the show Allison Janney.
How are you, Allison?
-Seth, I am so happy to see you.
I wish I were there with you
But I'm --
It feels like it's been year
since I've seen you.
-It's been a very long time,
and I also wish
you were here in person,
but I feel like
if you were here in person
I wouldn't be able to see
this incredible room
that you're in right now.
What is going on?
-Well, I tell you,
I made a simple request
of the set dec crew
at the "Mom" program to
zhuzh up my dressing room.
I thought maybe
a plant or something,
'cause I've been getting ver
high ratings on Room Rater
And I thought, "well, let's just
get me a plant or something.
And I walk in here today,
and I got a throne
and this guy and there's
just all sorts of things -
all sorts of things going on
-well, I will say,
all of it sort of brings out
the best in you.
You look fantastic, so
they know what they're doing
-Well, thank you.
-Tell me, are you enjoying -
you know, because I know
people are of two minds of it.
Do you like
doing press via Zoom,
or do you miss being live
in a studio?
-I feel less nervous
when I'm at home.
Because when you're there
in your studio
and there are all these people
and the audience and the energy,
I get terrified,
so I feel much more relaxed,
and that feels good to me.
But, I do, I mean, you know,
it's a love-hate thing.
I would love to be there
with you and see you,
because I always have
a good time with you.
So I'm kind of of both minds
I wonder if people will go bac
to -- you know, because
it's a lot of money
productions are saving
not having to fly me to New York
to do your show and
put me up in a fancy hotel
and all my fancy requests I need
to do, you know, to do things.
-Right, because you would need
like, a second plane ticke
for your crash test dummy.
That'd be a whole thing.
-Exactly, I have to take him
He's my emotional needs
crash test dummy.
-How has the COVID-19 protocol
life been
on set of a show that obviousl
you're so many seasons into it
It must be jarring
to be so different.
-It was, you know,
incredibly strange as acto
to have to cover your face
to rehearse,
because it's sort of
counterintuitive
to everything that an acto
needs to communicate.
So that part is weird.
It wasn't easy in the beginning.
But now we know we just do i
and we get tested.
I get tested two times a day
And for the rehearsals --
I mean, the run-throughs,
we're allowed
to take off the masks
and show everyone.
And they're so great,
the way they've done it here
We all have different zones.
Now I have to wear
a tracking thing
so they can tell
if I've been in contact
with someone
longer than five minutes
who was outside my zone.
So there's a lot more things
going on now,
and the thing's
still up the nose,
which I enjoy for some reason.
And I'm just grateful
that we're actually able to work
during this time.
Not too many people
have been that lucky.
-I feel lucky, as well,
to both be back to work
and also I think I enjoy
the thing up the nose, as well
-You do?
-I think I do.
I first dreaded it, and
now it's like a really nice wa
to sort of start the day.
-[ Chuckles ]
I do look forward to it.
Some of them don't do it
hard enough.
I'm like, "Can you do it
a little harder?"
-Right, yeah.
I mean, I do have a safe wor
with the people here.
[ Laughter ]
Which I highly recommend having.
-What's your safe word?
-[ Laughs ]
"No! Oh, God!"
[ Laughter ]
I guess it's three.
It's three safe words.
Hey, so, this is
a fantastic film
with just a wonderful
comedic cast.
You play a woman,
who we saw in the clip,
who sort of resorts to self-help
books and daily affirmations
Is that something that you'v
ever tried in your regular life?
-Are you kidding me?
Seth, if you could see
the library of books
that I've gotten from my mother,
from myself,
one even from
a boyfriend's mother,
which was slightly disturbing.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, I was like,
"Geez, am I that --"
you know, so I have delved
a lot into self-help.
I always loved
looking under my own rock
and seeing what's going on there
and why I act the way I act.
But I don't do the affirmations.
I don't know, ever since Stuar
Smalley,
I just think they're funny
So, you know, the only one I d
is I try to look in the mirror
in the morning
and say, "I love you,"
and say it until
I really mean it.
And sometimes, you know, som
days are better than others.
-You have -- We talked
before about how
after "The West Wing,"
you actually went
and saw a psychic to find ou
what was going to be next.
I'm wondering if you've returned
because you didn't necessarily
think you got the best advice.
But that did not turn you of
of the idea completely, right?
-I love going to psychics.
I really love
the whole experience.
I don't know why.
I feel like sometimes
it just puts a seed of hop
in your mind
when you hear something good
I mean, this one woman I went to
after I filmed "I, Tonya,"
but before any award thing
started happening,
she said, "I see a lot of gold
in your life.
I see a lot of gold."
And so but she also said
she saw a man --
a very handsome man --
that was coming into my life
and "you are going to have --"
it was going to be
a very sexual relationship
And she kept going on about him.
She said, "I think I'm going t
call him Hot Pants."
And so I was so excited.
I would go, you know --
if I didn't want to
go out to dinner,
I'd go, "I gotta go,
because maybe Hot Pants
is going to be there."
And he hasn't shown up yet
So she was right about
one thing, but no Hot Pants yet.
-She might not have
seen COVID coming,
which obviously
makes it very hard
for Hot Pants to meet anybody.
-That's true.
So he could be
as soon as he gets his vaccine
Maybe he'll show up.
Surely it can't be this guy.
-That would be heartbreaking
if that's who she meant.
[ Both laugh ]
Hey, it is always a deligh
to see you.
Congrats on the film.
Please do continue to stay saf
while you're filming.
-I will. And you too, Seth
It's really good to see you.
Thank you.
-You're very welcome.
"Mom" airs Thursday
at 9:00 p.m. on CBS,
and "Breaking News
in Yuba County" is
on digital and in select
theaters on February 12th.